on paper storage wars seems like an idea
that would have never worked but it did
watching people bid on storage
containers that have been abandoned by
their original owners just sounds
strange but viewers can't get enough and
they want to know more
well let's unlock the secret vault and
pour over some storage wars facts you
may not have known some of it's staged
storage wars is another reality show
that allegedly plays loose with the
definition of the word reality cast
member dave Hester approached producers
with concerns over the show's
authenticity numerous times in fact he
filed a lawsuit against the A&E Network
and original productions over those
concerns in 2012
Hester suspicions arose because whenever
he won a bid producers would draw his
attention to certain boxes or unload the
storage unit so he would discover
certain items like the time he found a
pile of old newspapers which announced
Elvis Presley's death or when he found a
car underneath a pile of trash a BMW
mini car to be exact
pester alleged that the producers were
planting valuable goods in the storage
units ahead of time to make the show
more interesting but that wasn't the
only reason Hester filed his lawsuit he
also alleged that Andy fired him from
the show after season 3 as a result of
his concerns each but Andy wasn't going
down without a fight
annie is a First Amendment proponent
oddly enough Annie didn't really deny
Hester's accusations the channel claimed
whatever behind-the-scenes actions it
took were protected by the First
Amendment
since storage wars isn't a game show the
producers can do as they please
Annie claimed Hester's lawsuit was
driven by Speights and nothing else when
all was said and done Hester was ordered
to pay Andy's legal fees but a judge
also ruled he could proceed with his
wrongful termination suit in the end
Hester and the network settled out of
court and he came back to the show with
season 5 jarrod schulz his dark past
though he may have Begley mentioned it a
few times on the show veteran bidder
jarrod schulz never elaborated on his
criminal past too bad for him that the
Internet is a thing ok magazine reported
in 2012 that Schultz was arrested for
felony possession of a controlled
substance narcotics transportation and a
DUI back in 1997 okay also reports that
in 1999 Schultz was busted again for
pretty much the same things
only this time he got a parole violation
added to his charges for his crimes
Schultz served a 16 month stretch in a
state prison there's no bidding for the
top bunk
Jarrod owes his fame to his aunt
according to the Orange County Register
jarrod schulz was having a rough go
staying afloat in the mortgage business
when he got his first whiff of storage
options from his aunt who at the time
was managing a public storage facility
over time he and his longtime partner
brandi passante would go on to open up
their own secondhand store now and then
how did they go from there to storage
wars it all went down at an auction in
Harbor City California where he met
producers who were planning storage wars
the rest of course is history mark
balelo's arrests and suicides in
February 2013 storage warrior mark
balelo was arrested for possession of
methamphetamine but not enough to
distribute meaning it was probably for
his own personal use this had happened
before to Hollywood Life reports that in
December 2007 he was arrested and
charged with three controlled substance
felonies sadly
balelo's latest arrest seemed to push
him over the edge as he committed
suicide just two days later via carbon
monoxide poisoning love at first sight
if you've ever wondered how Dan and
laura dotson have stayed solid all these
years it might have a little to do with
their relationships beginning I found
the right man because I am very
high-energy Laura told The Huffington
Post while discussing her relationship
with Dan whom she met in 1996 when I saw
him auctioneering all over the place I
thought I'm going to marry that man we
just looked at each other said let's get
married I'll snatch you up for months
later I was pregnant the whole doggone
thing she continued we work well
together he's taught me how to auction
and it's the best thing that's ever
happened in my life Dan suffered a
double brain aneurysm in 2014 dan and
Laura
helps care of their lives when Dan
suffered a double brain aneurysm in Palm
Springs California according to TMZ
Dan's condition was so bad when he got
to the hospital that he was given only a
4 to 20 percent chance of living
miraculously Dan's surgery turned out to
be a success he was released from the
hospital a little over a week later as
an added bonus Dan decided to quit
smoking after 40 years after his surgery
saved his life
Pirate's Booty talk about buried
treasure in 2011 TMZ reported that a
storage unit auctioned off by Dan and
laura dotson unknowingly contained about
$500,000 worth of Spanish gold dating
anywhere between the 16th and 19th
century the booty was discovered after
the storage unit had been auctioned off
it was reportedly located inside a real
pirate's chest that was at least 200
years old if that wasn't amazing enough
the report says the winning bidder made
off with the gold by paying a little
over $1,000 for the storage unit Barry
got his start in wholesale produce
speaking to Wisconsin's big cheese on
107.9 FM Barry Weiss who left the show
in 2013 revealed he worked for 30 years
in the wholesale produce business before
his storage wars Fame came about no
actually I was in the wholesale produce
business fruits and vegetables that sort
of thing but in pretty big volume we
provision everything from cruise ships
hotels restaurants that sort of thing
and so I was in that business
jeez 30 years and but he's been
collecting antiques on the side
collectibles wheeling and dealing
you know with with just kooky
off-the-wall objects so you know that
helped that helped a fun month a passion
for collecting weird it's like that old
saying when life gives you lemons make
lemonade or just sell enough of them
until you get a reality TV show thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what surprised you the
most about the cast of storage wars